हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग तो जो वेलकम टुडे
आप लोगों से वैसे भी रिक्वेस्ट किया था की
आज लास्ट दे है तो आप लोग को आगे अटेंड
करना चाहिए काफी इंपॉर्टेंट सेशन है
तो हम कंटिन्यू करेंगे इसको गेट पर वन
मिनट तो तब तक मुझे यह एक बात बता दीजिए
की आप सबको मेरी आवाज ए रही है नहीं ए रही
है बस आप ये कंफर्म कर दीजिए की आप सबको
मेरी आवाज ए रही है या नहीं ए रही है
प्लीज एक बार आप लोग मेरी आवाज कंफर्म कर
दीजिए सबको मेरी आवाज सही से सुने दे दिया
नहीं दे रही है
ओके चलो फिर हम अपने टॉपिक पे स्टार्ट
करते हैं और डोंट वेस्ट ओवर टाइम
इनको आना है ओके
चलो
भाई
ओके
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक रहेगा काफी लंबा
टॉपिक है और चलो हम बात करते हैं ठीक है
जो आज का हमारा टॉपिक है वह है
इसको हम बोलते हैं
इसके बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन
तो
देखो
सॉरी पर डिस्टरबेंस
नेटवर्क कम्युनिकेशन प्रोटोकॉल है जो क्या
कम करता है जो दो कंप्यूटर डिवाइसेज को
आपस में कम्युनिकेट करने का कम करता है
क्या
नेटवर्क
कम्युनिकेशन प्रोटोकॉल है
प्रोटोकॉल है जो क्या कम करता है जो आपके
दो कंप्यूटर डिवाइसेज दो कोई भी दो
कंप्यूटर डिवाइस इस हैं आपस में उनको
कम्युनिकेट करवाने का कम करता है क्या
करना है इनेबल्स
इनेबल तू
कंप्यूटर
23 एम यू एन आई सी कम्युनिकेट
और
शेर डाटा
किसी भी सर्वे के साथ अगर हमने रिमोट
एक्सेस चाहिए होता है अगर हमें क्या करना
है की पेट्रोल मशीन में हमने अपने कल निक
को रन किया हुआ है बट क्या है की मैंने
क्या किया की ये सर कम तो मेरा टर्मिनल का
ही है तो क्यों मैं बार-बार वर्चुअल मशीन
को ऑन करता हूं और उसको उसे करता हूं मैं
क्या कर सकता हूं जस्ट वर्चुअल मशीन को ऑन
करके उसको क्या है बैकग्राउंड में छोड़
देता हूं बार-बार मुझे उसको ओपन करना पड़ा
लोग इन करना पद रहा है उसकी बजे मैं क्या
कर सकता है उसको रीमोटली एक्सेस ले सकता
हूं हमारी भी मशीन से जो नॉर्मल अपना
होस्ट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है उससे मैं उसको
रीमोटली एक्सेस भी कर सकता हूं
तो वह अगर आपको उसको रीमोटली एक्सेस करना
है तो उसके लिए हम श प्रोटोकॉल का उसे
करते हैं
सीकर सेल
इसको सिक्योरिटी
बिकॉज़
जो कम्युनिकेशन है
मतलब क्या है की इसका मतलब
जो कम्युनिकेशन
होता है
एक है मोबाइल सरिता हो इनके थ्रू हम क्या
कर सकते हैं जब भी हम किसी भी मशीन को
रीमोटली एक्सेस करते हैं तो वो हम क्या
करते हैं उसमें स प्रोटोकॉल का उसे करते
हैं और ऐसे-ऐसे अपने कमांड भी है तो ऐसे
ऐसे प्रोटोकॉल क्या करता है की उसे सर्वर
के बीच में उसे मशीन के बीच में एक टनल
क्रिएट कर देता है और एक सिक्योरिटी टनल
क्रिएट कर देता है जिसके थ्रू क्या होता
है जिसमें जो भी डाटा शेर किया राहत है वो
क्या है इनफेक्टेड फॉर्म में डाटा शेर
किया जाता है तो
अब थोड़ा सा बात करते हैं इंक्रिप्ट
फॉर्मेट क्या होता है ये इंक्रिप्शन क्या
चीज होती है भैया देखो इंक्रिप्शन होती
क्या चीज है
तो बेसिकली क्या है की इंक्रिप्शन का क्या
मतलब होता है देखो अगला सवाल
क्या होता है
कन्वर्ट
मतलब क्या की जो आपका जो प्लेन टेक्स्ट है
अगर हम उसको किसी
एक ऐसी फॉर्म में कन्वर्ट कर देते हैं
यूनिडेबल फॉर्म में तो इसको हम बोल सकते
हैं प्लेन टेक्स्ट इसको हम बोल सकते हैं
अगर हम अपने प्लेन टेक्स्ट को कन्वर्ट कर
देते हैं अनरीड फॉर्म में जिसको आसानी से
पटना जा सके तो उसको बोलते हैं हम इन
दो टाइप्स के इंक्रिप्शन बेसिकली उसे किया
जाते हैं देवर तू टाइप्स ऑफ इंक्रिप्शन
डर आर
तेरे अरे दो
टाइप्स का इंक्यूशन
जो सेकंड टाइप है उसको हम बोलते हैं
समिटेड ए एस ए
टी आर एस मैट्रिक इंफेक्शन
आता है
वो क्या करता है
वह दो की उसे करता है दो की उसे करता है
तो मतलब क्या होता है की पब्लिक की शेर कर
दी जाति है किसी भी डाटा को क्या पर
एग्जांपल
प्राइवेट की
प्राइवेट
की प्राइवेट की क्रिएट करता है
आपने डाटा को सेंड करना है किसी को भी वो
क्या करेगा वो उसे डाटा को पहले क्या इसके
क्या करेगा ये और यूजर तू से कम्युनिकेशन
कर जाता है पर एग्जांपल ये यूजर तू से
कम्युनिकेट करना चाहता हूं तो यूजर वन
क्या करेगा यूजर वन
यूजर वन शेर इट्स
ओके
यूजर तू से क्या कर देगा शेर कर देगा
बोलेगा की हमारे बीच में जो भी
कम्युनिकेशन होगा आप जो भी डाटा मेरे साथ
शेर करना चाहते हो यूजर तू वो कैसे करना
है आपको मेरी पब्लिक की है उसको क्या करना
है इंक्रीस करना है
शेर करेगा डाटा तो वो
इनके वह उसे करेगा उसे
पब्लिक की ऑफ इसकी यूजर वन की तू
इंक्रिप्ट डाटा एंट्री डाटा को इंक्रिप्ट
करने के लिए अब इससे मैं फायदा क्या होता
है इससे फायदा यह होता है की अगर कोई
हैकर्स है या कोई भी अटैकर है अगर वो बीच
में डाटा को कैप्चर भी कर लेट है तो वो
इसको नहीं कर पाएगा क्या होता है
जिसके पास प्राइवेट की होगी तो अब यूजर वन
क्या कर सकता है यूजर वन इसको क्या कर
सकता है
यह जरूरी क्या करेगा की वह भी दो क्रिएट
करेगा एक पब्लिक की एक प्राइवेट की और
अपनी पब्लिक की यूजर वन के साथ शेर कर
देगा और ये जर्मन क्या बोलेगा
उनको बोलेगा की अगर आपको मेरे पास कोई भी
डाटा सेंड करना है तो आप मेरी पब्लिक के
साथ उसको इनपुट कर दीजिए और मेरे साथ शेर
कर दीजिए उससे फायदा यह है की उसे डाटा को
ओनली वही कर सकता है जिसके पास उसकी
प्राइवेट की होगी तो प्राइवेट की किसके
पास होगी यूजर हो के पास तो इसलिए
सोमेट्रिक इंक्रिप्शन सीकर होता है
क्योंकि एक तले की दो चाबी है जिसमें से
एक शादी जिसका वो ताला है उसके पास हमेशा
रहती है और दूसरी चाबी शेर कर दी जाति है
की जब भी आपको डाटा को शेर करना तो आपको
सर्विस उसको क्या कर दीजिए बैंड कर दीजिए
भाई लेकिन उसका फायदा यह है की उसे साले
को पुरी तरह फूल वही सकता है जिसके पास
दूसरी चाबी है
तो यह खेल होता है सर पब्लिक की और
प्राइवेट की का और जो आपका श है
जिसको हम बोलते हैं
बेसिकली क्या है की आप चाहे तो इसको अच्छी
तरह इंप्लीमेंट कर सकते हो अपने स
प्रोटोकॉल के अंदर लेकिन हां कंपनी
इंप्लीमेंट भी करती है अगर आप लोगों को
नहीं पता तो आज मैं इंप्लिकेट इंप्लीमेंट
आप लोगों को करके दिखाऊंगा
सॉरी यार थोड़ा सा क्या इलेक्ट्रिसिटी
प्रॉब्लम हुई थी उसकी वजह से आया था तो
शायद अभी भी ए रहा है की अभी नॉइस बताइए
एक बार थोड़ा सा
बताइए
ओके थैंक यू थैंक यू तो यह था सिमिट्रिक
इंक्रिप्शन और समित इंफेक्शन
के लिए एक ही की इकाई उसे करता है लेकिन
स्मृति के इंक्रिप्शन क्या करता है पब्लिक
को प्राइवेट की का उसे करता है प्राइवेट
की हमेशा उसे यूजर के पास रहती है जिसको
डाटा चाहिए होता है जो डाटा शेर करता है
उसको पब्लिक से शेर कर दी जाति है और
पब्लिक की के थ्रू वो क्या करना था बहन कर
देता है और डिस्क्रिप्शन वही कर सकता है
उसको जिसके पास उसकी प्राइवेट की होगी तो
इसी प्रकार से प्रोटोकॉल क्या करता है
प्रोटोकॉल जो है आपका स है ये उसे करता है
आरएसएस
करता है
लेकिन इसलिए
क्या करता है
यह एक छोटा सा ओवरव्यू था आपका
स के बड़े में अब बात करते हैं हम ऐश को
[संगीत]
अब बात करते हैं हम श के डिटेल के बड़े
में हम स्टार्ट करते हैं अभी हमारा
टर्मिनल से
चलो देखो अगर आपको अपने मशीन में लाइनेक्स
मशीन में अगर स को उसे करना है तो आपको
क्या करना पड़ेगा आपको उसे सबसे पहले उसका
पैकेज आपकी मशीन में इंस्टॉल करना पड़ेगा
जी पैकेज का होना चाहिए उसका नाम है
ट आपको क्या करना है इंस्टॉल करना है
तो अभी मेरी मशीन में पहले से ही ओपन एसेस
का पैकेज इंस्टॉल है इसलिए इंस्टॉल करने
की जरूर नहीं है अगर आपको स्क्रीन पर मैं
कमांड दिखा देता हूं की अगर आपको एसएमएस
प्रोटोकॉल को उसे करना है तो उसका ये
कमांड है शुद्ध अगर आप नॉर्मल यूजर से हो
तो आपको स्टूडियो ए पी टी इंस्टॉल ओपन
एक्सेस सर्वर ये पैकेज जब तक आपके मशीन
में इंस्टॉल नहीं होगा तब तक आप स की
सर्विस को उसे नहीं कर सकते अगर आप रूट
यूजर अकाउंट से तो आपको सुडो लगाने की
जरूर नहीं है ये आपको अच्छी तरह से पता है
नेक्स्ट उसके बाद जब एक बार आपने अपनी
मशीन में पैकेज को इंस्टॉल कर लिया उसके
बाद आपको से की सर्विस को स्टार्ट करना है
आपको दो तरीके से चेक कर सकते हो क्या ऐसी
आर वे आई सी सर्विस उसके बाद चेक कर सकते
हो एस टी ए टी यू एस स्टेटस
अगर आपको एसएमएस की सर्विस को स्टार्ट
करना है तो आपको क्या करना है
क्या जितना सर्विस स्टार्ट सर्विस स्टार्ट
देखो तरीका होता है कौन सा होता है सिस्टम
सिस्टम
[संगीत]
हा टी ए आर टी स्टार्ट और से उसे सर्विस
का नाम जिसको आप स्टार्ट करना चाहते लेकिन
आपको सुडो उसे करना पड़ेगा सव और सुडो तो
हिट इंटर तो ये भी क्या करेगा आपकी सर्विस
को स्टार्ट कर देगा अगर आप देखना चाहते हो
की आपकी मशीन में ये एसएससी सर्विस
स्टार्ट हुई या नहीं हुई उसके लिए कमांड
होती है
सुडो उसके बाद सिस्टम सीटीएल सिस्टम
सिस्टम सीटीएल उसके बाद एस टी ए टी स्टेबल
एस टी ए टी यू एस स्टेटस उसके बाद देखोगे
की आपकी जो सर्विस दिखाई दे रही है आपको
स्क्रीन पर मैं थोड़ा सा जूम कर दे जो नोट
कर देता हूं
अगर आपको दूसरी कमांड से देखना तो वो भी
देख सकते हो
स्टेटस एस टी ए टी यू एस स्टेटस तो ये
क्या करेगा
इसको क्या करना है स्टॉप करना है तो आपको
सिंपली क्या लिखना है छोड़ो क्योंकि मैं
नॉर्मल यूजर से हूं उसके बाद सर्विस
सर्विस उसके बाद क्या करना है
सिंपली तो यह क्या करते हैं आपकी से की
सर्विस को क्या कर देगा स्टॉप कर देगा अभी
क्या है ये स्टॉप
ओके कमाने के लिए सूट ऑन हनी थी
एस यू डू आईटी इंटर तो इसने क्या कर दिया
आपकी सर्विस को स्टॉप कर दिया अगर आप
स्टेटस देखना चाहते हो तो आप देख सकते हो
ये स्टेटस आपके एसएससी सर्विस का तो अभी
आपकी आईएनएक्टिव है स की सर्विस जो आपको
स्क्रीन पे दिखाई दे रही होगी
आज मैं फिर से स्टार्ट कर देता हूं अपनी
से की सर्विस को दोनों तरीके से देख सकते
हैं दोनों तरीके से हम क्या कर सकते हैं
इसको स्टार्ट कर सकते हैं स्टॉप कर सकते
हैं इसका स्टेटस देख सकते हैं तो यहां तक
सबको समझ में ए गया होगा की कैसे आपको
सर्विस स्टार्ट करनी है दूसरा अगर आप
म्युचुअल मशीन में आपकी अपने क्या कर रहे
हो
अपनी मशीन को तो आपको क्या करना है की
तो आपका नेटवर्क सेटिंग है वहां पर जाकर
आपको क्या करना चाहिए था मैं आपको दिखा
देता हूं
मैं क्या करता हूं ये रहा जब आपका क्या
करोगे आपकी मशीन पर राइट क्लिक करोगे आपको
सेटिंग में जाना है उसके बाद आपको क्या
देखना है की जो आपको नेटवर्क कनेक्ट दिखाई
दे रहा होगा यहां पर ये आपका ब्रिज मोड
में होना चाहिए एडरवाइज आप अच्छे से उसे
नहीं कर पाओगे बेसिकली क्या है की आपको इस
लाइन में होना पड़ेगा उसे करना है तो अभी
क्योंकि हम यहां पोर्ट फोल्डिंग वाला हम
क्या इन लेंथ लोकल एरिया लैंड के अंदर ही
अगर आप कोई रीमोटली एक्सेस करना सर्वर को
कैसे करना है वो आपको मुझे का रहा हूं
ये था अब मुझे क्या करना है ठीक है मेरी
अब स की सर्विस स्टार्ट होगी तो एक चीज
दिखा देता हूं आपको जब भी आप स का पैकेज
इंस्टॉल करते हैं अपनी मशीन में तो
उसका मैसेज इंस्टॉल करते हैं तो आपको एक
लोकेशन दिखता हूं एलएस करता हूं आईफोन लड
करता हूं और उसके बाद ईटीसी के अंदर ईटीसी
के अंदर
ही बन जाता हूं बार-बार प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट
कर रहा है
ओके मैं क्या करता हूं चिड़िया करता हूं
आईफोन ल ए देखो जब भी आप क्या करते हो जब
भी आप से ओपन स वाले पैकेज को अपनी मशीन
में इंस्टॉल करते हैं तो बाय डिफॉल्ट यहां
पर वह साड़ी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स क्या हो
जाति है क्रिएट हो जाति है ईटीसी के अंदर
से के अंदर और जो ये फाइल बताइए मैंने
एटीसी के अंदर जो एसेस वाली है ये इस स की
में कॉन्फ़िगरेशन डायरेक्टली है जिसके
अंदर आपको बहुत साड़ी फाइल्स जो
डायरेक्टली देखने को मिलेगी पर एग्जांपल
ये रही आपको ये रही ये बैनर टी नहीं
मिलेगी ये ऐसा सच कौन थी से कॉन्फ़िग डोंट
बी डायरेक्टली से एचडी कौन थी ऐसा सच
कंफीग्य ये फिर
से की सीडी से ki.com लेक एड ये रहा और
ऐसे की और पब्लिक ये आपको देखने को मिला
होगा ये एक दस से क्या होता है इलेक्ट्रिक
जो आपको ये फाइल दिखाई दे रही है तो आपको
मैं दिखा रहा हूं ये डॉट
से कनफ्लिक्ट और एसडी कनफ्लिक्ट यह बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट फाइल्स है जो आपकी फर्स्ट वाली
फाइल दिखाई दे रही है
से की कंफीग्रेशन फाइल्स है उसकी
कंफीग्रेशन फाइल है और जो से एचडी
कनफ्लिक्ट फाइल है या आपकी जो डेमों
सर्विस है उसकी कंफीग्रेशन फाइनल डेमन
सर्विस क्या होती है जितनी भी जो आपके
पैकेज इंस्टॉल करते हैं तो पैकेज इंस्टॉल
करने के बाद क्या उसकी एक सर्विस क्रिएट
होती है सर्विस एक प्रोसेस क्रिएट होती है
समझे तो उसे प्रोसेस को हम सर्विस बोलते
हैं और उसे सर्विस को हम क्या बोलते हैं
की डेमों बोलते हैं डेमों लाइनस में क्या
बोला जाता है डायमंड तो यही वो है ये
डायमंड उसे डायमंड सर्विस की कंफीग्रेशन
फाइल क्या है से एचडी कनफ्लिक्ट के नाम से
इसको डायमंड सॉल्यूशन फाइल मिलेगी बाकी जो
और भी फाइल्स है मैंने आपको बता दिया ये
उसकी रिलेटेड फाइल्स है रिलेटेड अब क्या
है की आपको मैंने बताइए वो पब्लिक की और
प्राइवेट की का उसे करता है और साथ में
एल्गोरिथम का उसे करता है
तो ये आपकी में कंफीग्रेशन फाइल थी अगर
कोई आपसे पूछता है जो आपका स है तो उसकी
में कंफीग्रेशन फाइल कहां पे मिलेंगे तो
आपको मिलेगी उसकी जो लोकेशन है वो ए टी सी
के अंदर स के अंदर जाके देखने को मिलेगी
हम आपको सीखना हूं की आपको रीमोटली एक्सेस
कैसे कर सकते हैं आप कैसे एक दूसरी मशीन
के थ्रू आप इसी मशीन को एक्सेस कर सकते हो
क्लियर कर देता हूं मैं स्क्रीन को तो अभी
मैं आपको दिखता हूं मेरा आईएफ कनफ्लिक्ट
करके दिखता हूं तो मेरा आईपी एड्रेस है इस
मशीन का वो है
192.168.148 मेरा इसका आईपी एड्रेस है अब
जब भी इसे एक सिंटेक्स होता है जब भी आप
किसी मशीन में असेल्स के थ्रू रिमोट
एक्सेस लेने की कोशिश करोगे किसी भी मशीन
को जैसे मैं आप मेरी काली की मशीन आएगी
इसको मुझे अगर अपनी विंडो की मशीन से
विमोली एक्सेस करना है तो उसका एक
सिंटेक्स होता है हम आपको कमेंट डॉ करके
दिखता हूं आपको लिखोगे ऐसे-ऐसे कमांड का
नाम उसके बाद क्या लिखोगे यूजर नाम फिर
उसके बाद @ यह सिंटेक्स बता रहा हूं मैं
उसके बाद क्या लिखोगे वो आईपी एड्रेस वो
आईपी एड्रेस या आपको क्या ले सकता हूं
पोस्ट नाम भी लिख सकते हो
ओके बट क्या है बेस्ट आईपी एड्रेस सो
उसके बाद क्या पासवर्ड क्या करेगा
यूजरनेम आते डी रेट और आईपी एड्रेस अभी
मैं आपको लेक जाता हूं मेरी मोबाइल
एक्सट्रीम जहां से मैं आपको एक मिनट लेकर
जाता हूं या ना ये रहा तो वहां पे ये
विंडो मशीन पे जाता हूं यहां पर मेरा क्या
है की मोबाइल एक्सट्रीम है आप चाहे तो
पुट्टी से भी कर सकते हो लेकिन मैं मोबाइल
स्क्रीन को ज्यादा प्रेफर करता हूं
क्योंकि इसमें आप मल्टीप्लेक्स मशीन को एक
साथ क्या कर सकते हो रिमोट एक्सेस कर सकते
हो तो यहां पर जाऊंगा तो रिमोट एक्सेस
करने के लिए मैं क्या करता हूं अच्छे से
किया है मैंने वही आपके
मैं इसको जूम कर देता हूं थोड़ा सा आपको
अच्छे से दिखाई दे झूठ झूठ झूठ झूठ उसके
बाद फिर से झूठ ओके अभी आपको दिखाई दे रहा
होगा तो ऐसे जैसे लिखूंगा उसे कमांड का
नाम उसके बाद मैं यूजर नाम तो मैं यूजर
नाम क्या है काली उसके बाद @ उसके बाद में
क्या आईपीएल 199
मेरा क्या था आईपी एड्रेस किया मैंने अभी
उसने किया गया आपको पासवर्ड के लिए
प्रोवाइड किया तो मेरा जो इसका पासवर्ड
इंटर कर दूंगा
इंटर अब क्या हुआ की यह क्या हो गया
उसके अंदर क्या करके इंटर करें देखो ये
आपको दिखाई दे रहा होगा आगे आईटी इसे
इंटरफेस जैसा वहां पर दिखाई दे रहा था
टर्मिनल ऐसा यहां पे दिखा रहा है अगर मैं
आपको कंफर्म करना है तो सिंपली आप कमांड
चलाएं देख सकते हो नाम तो ये आप उसे हो
गया है काली अगर आपको ये कंफर्म करना की
यूजर कौन सा है
उसके बाद डॉलर और यूजर का नाम यूजर नाम
क्या है उस यूजर तो ये आपको दिखाएगा ओके
काली ही इसका उसे है अब मैं क्या करता हूं
मैं स्विच करके दिखता हूं अगर आपको रूट बन
के दिखता हूं अगर आपको यकीन नहीं हो तो एस
यू डू
आईटी इंटर किया मैंने और उसके बाद फिर से
पासवर्ड डाला
@@
होम काली है अगर एलएस करके दिखाओ
हमारी काली मशीन के अंदर है अगर आपको नहीं
यकीन होता तो मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं
चैनल के ऊपर यह रहा और मर्सिडीज़ करता हूं
टेंडर और
सीडी स्लैश होम फ्लैश
करता हूं तो यह साड़ी फाइल्स डायरेक्टली
इधर दिखाई दे रही है ये साड़ी फाइल हमारी
एक्सट्रीमली स्ट्रिंग पर दिखाई दे रहे हो
इस तरीके से हम किसी भी मशीन को रीमोटली
एक्सेस कर सकते हैं इन डी लोकल एरिया
नेटवर्क अपने लैंड के अंदर ओके तो एक ये
तरीका था की आपको क्या करने का अपनी मशीन
को अब मैं इसको आउट कर देता हूं एग्जिट कर
देता हूं इसके बाद एग्जिट कर देता हूं आप
एक चीज आपको सीखना हूं अगर आप क्या चाहते
हो आप चाहते हो की मैं बिना लॉगिन किया
किसी भी मशीन में कमांड एग्जीक्यूटिव मैं
अगर मैं चाहता हूं की जो मेरी काली मशीन
है अगर मैं बिना लॉगिन किया इसके अंदर
क्या करना चाहता हूं कमांड को एग्जीक्यूट
करना चाहता हूं मुझे लॉगिन नहीं करना बट
मैं क्या अपनी कमांड आउटपुट देखना चाहता
हूं वो भी कर सकते हो कैसे सिंपली श उसके
बाद क्या करोगे
प्लस
192.168.1
सिंपली आपको क्या करना है उसे कमांड का
नाम जो आप फायर करना चाहते हो मैं क्या
करना चाहता हूं मैं देखना चाहता हूं होस्ट
नाम होस्ट नाम कमांड में एग्जीक्यूट करना
चाहता हूं सिंपली हिट इंटर अब ये क्या
करेगा जैसे आप पासवर्ड डॉग तो ये उसे मशीन
के अंदर क्या करेगा अभी लॉगिन नहीं करेगा
बस लोग इन करके कमांडो फॉर्म क्योंकि
मैंने कमांड गलत लिखी थी अब मैं होस्ट हा
ओ एस टी एन ए एम ए हॉर्स नाम पोस्ट नाम
इसे स्पेलिंग है ओके फिर से मैं करता हूं
ये देखिए अभी इसने क्या किया लॉगिन नहीं
किया लेकिन उसे कमांड का आउटपुट आपकी
स्क्रीन पे शो कर दिया प्रिंट करके दिया
ऐसे अगर मैं पीडी करूं तो पीडी भी कर सकता
हूं
और फिर से मैं पासवर्ड अटेंड कर दो
कर रहा है तो इस तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते
हो किसी भी कमांड में किसी भी कमांड को
फायर कर सकते हैं बिना लॉगिन
उसे कर रहे हो आप चाहते हो की एक मशीन से
दूसरी मशीन में ऐसे उसके थ्रू किसी फाइल
को शेर करना चाहते हो तो वो भी कर सकते
हैं मैं आपको एक और एग्जांपल देखने देता
हूं पर एग्जांपल मेरे पास एक दो मशीन उसे
करूंगा अभी मैं इसको बैंड कर देता हूं अभी
के लिए ओके
मेरे पास रेड मशीन है मेरे पास रेड
इंटरप्राइजेज मेरे पास एक
की मशीन है ओके
टर्मिनल है
पर एग्जांपल
मैंने क्या किया टच किया टच और मैं क्या
करता हूं
कैलेंडर दाल दिया
फाइल के अंदर
कैच करके दिखता हूं आपको डेमो नोट
कैलेंडर है अब मैं क्या चाहता हूं की इस
फाइल को मेरी काली उसकी मशीन है उसके ऊपर
क्या करना चाहता हूं मैं शेर करना चाहता
हूं तो कैसे कर सकता हूं उसके लिए कमांड
होती है एस सी पी एस सी पी क्योंकि ये
काफी हेल्प आएगी जब भी आप कहानी कोई ईटीएफ
खेलोगे क्योंकि आज का जो टॉपिक है ना बहुत
ही ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है बहुत ही ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट क्योंकि जब भी आप क्या करोगे
तो आपको कैसे उनको ऑन करना होगा क्योंकि
जब तक अगर आपको असेट्स के बड़े में कोई
नॉलेज नहीं है ना कुछ नहीं कर सकते ओके तो
एस सी पी और अगर आपको फाइल शेर करने की
नौबत ए जाए तो ऐसे भी करना है साप आईफोन
आर आईफोन
उसके बाद मैं क्या करना था फूल पद देना
पड़ेगा मुझे स्लैश होम
स्लैश मैट्रिक्स
इसके अंदर कौन सी है डेमो डॉट टी एक्स टी
उसके बाद में किसको शेर करना चाहता हूं
काली उसके बाद @
192.168.148
इंटर मैंने कर दिया इंटर कर दिया हिट
क्यों
इसका पासवर्ड के लिए फ्रॉम नहीं किया
एक्चुअल में करना क्यों नहीं किया है
क्योंकि इससे पहले आपके क्लास में से पहले
मैं आपके लिए प्रैक्टिस करके आया था तो
उसमें क्या था की मैंने क्या कर गया
ऑथेंटिकेशन ली प्रोटोकॉल को उसको
कॉन्फ़िगर किया हुआ इसलिए इसने पासवर्ड के
लिए प्रॉन्प्ट नहीं किया तो अभी मैं जाके
हम आप निकाल मशीन पे जाते हैं खाली की
मशीन पर शिफ्ट करते हैं 1 मिनट
[संगीत]
यार
काली उसके बाद आपको
कोलोन उसके बाद आपको क्या करना कोलन देने
के बाद आपको क्या करना है कोलन देने के
बाद आपको पास मेंशन करना है पहले तो एक
फोर्ड स्लैश उसके बाद आपको पांच मेंशन
करना मैं कहां पर देना चाहता हूं मैं होम
उसके बाद क्या है काली के अंदर मैं इसको
क्या करना चाहता हूं शेर करना था हिट इंटर
अभी हां अभी ये कमांड से इसे फायर ओके
आईटी इंटर अब ये देखना इसने क्या कर दिया
डेमो थी फाइल को क्या करते हैं बहुत ही
सीकर तरीके से शेर कर दो आईटी इस वेरी
सिक्योर्ड वे ऐसा कुछ नहीं की सीकर नहीं
है काफी सिक्योरिटी है इस तरीके से अगर आप
फाइल शेर करोगे तो कंप्रोमाइज नहीं होगी
तो अब ये है अब मैं काली के मशीन पे जाता
हूं और मैं क्या करता हूं अलेक्स कर देता
हूं देखो यहां पर एक डेमो डीएक्सट के नाम
की फाइल आपको देखने को मिल रही होगी जो
पहले से नहीं थी अगर हम क्या करेंगे कैट
करके देखेंगे डेमो डॉट टी एक्स टी के अंदर
तो आपको देखने को मिलेगा की ये कैलेंडर जो
हमने वहां पर आपके सामने इस फाइल के अंदर
पट किया था तो आपको समझ में ए गया की एक
तो कैसे आपको रीमोटली आपकी मशीन को एक्सेस
करना है किसी टर्मिनल से दूसरा आपको मैंने
बताया की अगर आपको मशीन में लॉगिन नहीं
किया बिना लॉगिन किया आपको मशीन में कमांड
फायर करने तो वो भी कैसे कर सकते हैं
तीसरी चीज मैंने आपको क्या बताई की अगर आप
कोई भी फाइल से शेर करना चाहते हैं
तो कैसे कर सकते हैं तो एस सी पी कमांड का
उसे कर सकते अगर मैं आपको यहां पर
सिंटेक्स लिख के दिखा देता हूं
एसपी उसके बाद है
उसके बाद क्या लिखना है आपको
यूजरनेम मशीन को हम भेजना चाहते हैं
कोलोन उसके बाद कोलोन उसके बाद एक फोटो
स्लैश उसके बाद फिर
मैं उसको शेर करना चाहता हूं एब्सलूट पाठ
की बात करें यह है इसका सिंटेक्स चलो अब
आगे बढ़ते हैं की अब तो मैंने आपको बता
दिया की ये कैसे आप अगर मैं पासवर्ड ली
ऑथेंटिकेशन सेट करना चाहता हूं तो कैसे कर
सकता हूं
मतलब अभी तक नाम क्या कर रहे थे जब भी हम
कमांड को उसे कर रहे थे यह क्या कर रहा था
यह एक पासवर्ड मांग रहा था आपसे क्या मांग
रहा था पासवर्ड की काली आप करके उसका
पासवर्ड बना देता है अब मैं चाहता हूं की
दिउ तू सिक्योरिटी पर या आस होर्डिंग परपज
मैं क्या कहना चाहता हूं की मैं पासवर्ड
ली ऑथेंटिकेशन बनाना चाहता हूं ऐसी
रिटायरमेंट का पड़ती है पर एग्जांपल आप
ऐसी जगह कम करते हो पब्लिक प्लेस में बैठ
के आप क्या कर रहे हो पब्लिक प्लेस में
बैठ के कम कर रहे हो और वहां पर आपको क्या
है की आपको लगता है की बहुत सारे लोग आते
जाते हैं कोई आपको पीछे से बैठ के देख रहा
है कोई कुछ कर रहा है उससे क्या हो सकता
है ए यार तो उससे क्या होगा की आपका
पासवर्ड किसी को भी पता चल जाएगा कुछ
कीवर्ड कुछ भी हो आसानी से कर सकता है अगर
आप सिक्योरिटी परपज से क्या करोगे आप
चाहते हो की मैं बार-बार पासवर्ड टाइप ना
करना पड़े कोई मेरे पासवर्ड शोल्डर सर
अपना कर पे कोई भी देखना चाहे कंधे के ऊपर
से तो क्या करना करोगे आप पासवर्ड लेते
ऑथेंटिकेशन भी सेट कर सकते हैं जो अभी मैं
बताया था की इंफेक्शन का उसे करके पब्लिक
प्राइवेट की का
तो वह कैसे कर सकते हैं देखो तो जब भी आप
ओपन एसएमएस का एक पैकेज इंस्टॉल करते हैं
तो क्या होता है की आपकी जो होम
डायरेक्टरी होती है जो आपकी होम
डायरेक्टरी होती है ना उसके अंदर पर
एग्जांपल रूट के लिए सेट करता हूं तो मैं
रूट के लिए मैं नॉर्मल डिलीवरी के लिए सेट
करूंगा अभी एग्जिट करता हूं ओके ये मेरी
उम्र ऐसी है पीडी जब भी आप क्या करते हो
की ओपन एसेस का पैकेट इंस्टॉल करते हैं तो
एलएस आईफोन जब ये ल करोगे तो आपको एक
डायरेक्टर या देखने को मतलब क्या करता है
की आपको
एक डायरेक्टर क्रिएट हो गया मिल जाति है
डॉट स के नाम के डॉट हिडन ऐसे ही नाम के
एक डायरेक्टली क्रिएट हो जाति है जब भी आप
क्या कर सकते हो ओपन इसका पैकेज इंस्टॉल
करते हैं लेकिन
मैक्सिमम मशीन में यह कम करती है मैक्सिमम
मशीन में क्या होता है बाय डिफॉल्ट डॉट स
वाले डायरेक्टली क्रिएट हो जाति है लेकिन
काली मशीन में एक प्रॉब्लम है
मतलब जब भी आपको सीकर
पासवर्ड
क्रिएट करनी होगी ये डायरेक्टली आपको क्या
करनी पड़ेगी क्रिएट करनी होगी आपकी मशीन
में एक की रेट नहीं हुई होगी मेरी में भी
नहीं हुई थी क्योंकि बाकी किसी फीडबैक
सिस्टम में आप उसे करो तो बाय डिपोज आपको
देखने को मिलती है या किसी और सिस्टम में
बाय डिफॉल्टर डॉट एसेस क्रिएट हो जाति है
बट कई मशीन ऐसी हैं जो लेटेस्ट वाली जिम
बाय डिफॉल्टर ये ग्रेट हो नहीं रही है
क्योंकि जब तक आप पासवर्ड
पासवर्ड तो पहले हम आपको दिखता हूं की इस
डायरेक्टर के अंदर होता क्या मैं एक बार
सीडी करता हूं डॉट के अंदर अब इसके अंदर
कुछ भी नहीं है अभी इसके अंदर कुछ भी नहीं
होता है लेकिन इसके अंदर एक फाइल देखने को
मिलती है क्या देखने को फाइल अजीज क्या
राहत है नॉन हॉर्स जहां पे एक बार आपको
देखने को मिलेगी नॉनस्ट या आपको बता रहा
हूं की कहानी भी अगर आप लाइनेक्स
प्लेस्टेशन करो कई बार इस टाइप से आपको
फाइल देखने को मिलती है तो नॉन होस्ट में
क्या इनफॉरमेशन रहती है जो नॉनस्टॉप होती
है ना उसमें जो आपके नॉन जो यूजर्स हैं
उनके
पब्लिक की अवेलेबल मिलती है यहां पर उनकी
क्या मिलती है आपको पब्लिक की देखने को
मिलती है नॉन हॉर्स की समझे नॉन हॉर्स कौन
सी होगी जिनके साथ कम्युनिकेट कर रहे हो
जिनके साथ आपका कम्युनिकेशन स्टडीज हुआ है
उसकी इनफॉरमेशन इसके अंदर नॉन-होस्ट के
अंदर मिल जाति है वो पब्लिक पब्लिक की
आपको देखने को मिलती है तो
है तो अभी बात करते हैं पर एग्जांपल मैंने
क्या किया हमारे आपकी उसमें एलएस हिफिन जब
आपने अल किया तो आपकी मशीन में
ओके हेलो
हिडन जो आपकी डॉट एस एस वाली फाइल है हिडन
फाइल है नहीं तो आप सिंपली मैं क्या करता
है एक बार इसको रिमूव कर देता हूं आराम है
उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं स को मैं क्या
करता है एक बार रिमूव कर देता हूं की
सेंटर कर दिया मैंने अब मैं क्या करना है
अगर आपकी मशीन में अगर डॉट एशेज वाली
डायरेक्टली क्रिएट नहीं है डोंट वारी
चिंता करने की जरूर नहीं है अभी मैं आपको
सारे स्टेप के साथ दिखता हूं की कैसे आप
पासवर्ड ली होता दे गैसों
तो एक चीज ध्यान रखना
सेट करना चाहते हैं जी भी यूजर के लिए सेट
करना चाहते हैं पर एग्जांपल किसके लिए
बताता हूं की मेरी जो काली मशीन है मैं इस
से जो रेड की जो मेरी मशीन सर्वर है मैं
उसको क्या करना चाहता हूं उसके साथ एक
पासवर्ड ली ऑथेंटिकेशन तो किसके साथ बताना
है उसके साथ में पासवर्ड ली ऑथेंटिकेशन
बनाना चाहता हूं की मतलब मैं और मेरा जो
सर्वर है और मैं काली लाइनेक्स मुझे मेरी
मशीन है अगर हम कंपनी गेट करें तो हम क्या
है पासवर्ड ली कम्युनिकेट करें तो जी भी
मशीन में आप पासवर्ड ली ऑथेंटिक बना राहत
हूं ध्यान रख जिसमें मशीन में तो उसमें
मशीन में आपको क्या करना है आपको सबसे
पहले आपकी डॉट एसएससी वाली डायरेक्टली
क्रिएट हो जानी चाहिए पहले बात अगर नहीं
भी है तो क्या होगा
ले तो मैं आपको स्टेप क्या बताता हूं आपको
सिंपली क्या करना है एम के लिए तैयार करना
है और उसके बाद क्या करना है आपको
डायरेक्टली क्रिएट करनी है
उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है इस पे परमिशन
सेट करनी है जो डायरेक्टली एलएस आईफोन अगर
मैं
और करके दिखता हूं तो इसकी परमेश्वर आपको
क्या दिखाई दे रही होगी
750 दिखाई दे रही होगी तो अभी इसकी जो
परमिशन होती है जो डॉट एस एस ए जो
डायरेक्ट भी आई है उसकी जो परमेश्वर होती
है वो 700 होती है तो क मोड मैं क्या करता
हूं उसके बाद सेवन उसके बाद 700 उसके
परमिशन दाल देता हूं डॉट स वाले जो
डायरेक्टली हैं उसके ऊपर ऑपरेशन डेल राइट
हैंड अब मैं एलएस हिफिन ए ल करता हूं पहले
सेफोन आईफोन अल करता हूं आईटी इंटर तो अब
आपको जो परमिशन दिखाई दे रही होगी डॉट
एसेस वाली फाइल के ऊपर वो कौन सी है सेवन
जीरो जीरो ओनली रूट यूजर को जो उसका ओनर
उसको क्या है रेड परमिशन है उसके अलावा
सबको क्या है वो कोई भी परमिशन नहीं है तो
अब आपको क्या करोगे सिंपली आपको क्या करना
है शिरडी करना है और मैं क्या ए गया सीडी
किया और मैं इसके अंदर जाता हूं तो मैं
जाता हूं 3d
डॉट स के अंदर चला जाता हूं ये आपकी जो
फाइल है आपकी होम डायरेक्टरी में क्रिएट
होगी ये जो डायरेक्टली
आप इसके अंदर कुछ भी नहीं है तो यहां पर
कमांड चलानी है
अब यह क्या बोल रहा है की आपको बोल रहा है
की जेनरेटिंग पब्लिक प्राइवेट की सा की पर
इंटर फाइल इन विच यू वांट तू से अब यह
क्या है की अगर
जी भी
हुंडई
क्या कहना चाहते थे पासवर्ड
की जैन कमांडर उसे करोगे तो उसमें अगर
मैंने तो क्या है की आपको डॉट एसएससी
डायरेक्टली किया है क्रिएट करके दिखा दी
बट क्या आपको क्रिएट करने की वजह से जरूर
नहीं थी क्योंकि यह बाय डिफॉल्टर से आईडी
क्या कर देता आपकी जो डायरेक्टली उसको
क्रिएट कर देता उसके बाद उसमें इदरसा करके
आपकी प्राइवेट की पब्लिक की स्टोर कर देता
अब ये बोल रहा था की अगर आपको कुछ इसको
किसी और लोकेशन में शेर करना चाहते हो
नहीं मैं इसको इंटर कर दिया
आप यहां पर क्या है की पासवर्ड डालिए क्या
आप क्या चाहते हो की जो आपकी जो प्राइवेट
की है उसमें कोई पासवर्ड होना चाहिए या
नहीं होना चाहिए एक चीज ध्यान रखना
पासवर्ड रखना आपका आपके लिए एक और स्टेप
है आपके लिए एक और
स्टेप है कैसे
पर एग्जांपल आपके सामने अब हुआ क्या की एक
एग्जांपल लेते हैं
की आपने क्या किया की
मैं भूल गया
पासवर्ड अपनी मशीन में सेट कर दिया लेकिन
अगर सोचो अगर किसी यूजर को अगर किसी यूजर
को आपकी प्राइवेट की मिल गई तो तब क्या
करोगे तब भी तो उनसे क्यों ना तो अब आप
क्या कर रहे हो की अगर आप चाहते हो की
मेरी प्राइवेट की कोई पासवर्ड होना चाहिए
मैं अपनी प्राइवेट की को क्या करना चाहता
हूं सिक्योरिटी करना चाहता हूं शो डेट की
जब भी मैं क्या करूं जब भी मैं पासवर्ड ली
हो तो इंडिकेशन उसे करूं तो वहां पर मैं
क्या करूं की मैं अपने यूजर्स है उसका
पासवर्ड ना दाल के मैं कौन से जो प्राइवेट
की है उसका पासवर्ड उसे करो तो आप ऐसा भी
कर सकते हैं अभी मैं क्या करना हो इस पे
कोई भी पासवर्ड सेट नहीं कर रहा कोई भी तो
इसमें एमपी छोड़ रहा हूं
इंटर कर दिया जिसने क्या कर दिया
आपको यहां पर क्या है दो की जेनरेट कर दिए
एक तो आईआरएस से ये आपकी प्राइवेट की है
यह आईडी आरएसएस पब्लिक यह पब्लिक की है जो
पब्लिकली कोई भी देश हम आपको कैट करके
दिखा देता हूं इदरीसी पब्लिक की दिखाऊंगा
प्राइवेट नहीं दिखाऊंगा जब मेरी भी
प्राइवेसी है
इंटर के
कैट तो नहीं कर यार
हमने पब्लिक को प्राइवेट की जेनरेट कर ली
अब मुझे क्या करना है उसके
साथ सीकर कंपनी करना है तो मैं कैसे
करूंगा
की जो मेरी पब्लिक की है इसको शेर करूंगा
इस पब्लिक एक मैं क्या करूंगा शेर कर
दूंगा किसके साथ मेरे
साड़ी चीजों उल्टी हो रही है ओके तो इस
पब्लिक की को मैं क्या करूंगा शेर करूंगा
मेरे रेड सर्वर के साथ लेकिन मैं शेर कैसे
करूंगा या तो मैं क्या करूंगा
किसी
यस में लूंगा इस की को स्टोर करूंगा उसके
बाद उसके सर्वर पर जाऊंगा और उसको मैं
क्या कर दूंगा यह शेर कर दूंगा अब यस वाला
पॉसिबल नहीं है क्योंकि सर्वर में कोई भी
आपको एंट्री नहीं देगा तो ठीक है हम ऐसा
कर सकते हैं की अभी मैं एक बार अपने रेटेड
सर्वर पे जाता हूं यह रहा मेरा रेड सर्वर
को ये रहा ओके
फोन ऑन हो जो भैया मैं यहां पर यह चेक
करता हूं क्या यह डायरेक्टली यहां पर
क्रिएट हो राखी है या नहीं है अगर ये
क्रिएट नहीं होगा करनी पड़ेगी
ओके
क्लियर करके दिखता हूं स्क्रीन पर यह मेरा
क्या है
पीडी प्रेसिडेंट वर्किंग
क्रिएट हो राखी है पहले से अगर आपके उसमें
अगर आपको दूसरी मशीन आपको उसे करनी ही
पड़ेगी अगर इस टाइप का एक्सपेरिमेंट करना
है तो मेरे पास ऑलरेडी दो लाइनेक्स मशीन
है इसलिए मैं एक्सपेरिमेंट करके दिखा रहा
हूं तो अब क्या है की अगर मुझे इसके साथ
अब क्या है पासवर्ड इंडिकेशन करना तो मेरे
इस मशीन के अंदर डॉट नाम के डायरेक्टर हनी
चाहिए अगर आपकी मशीन में डायरेक्ट क्रिएट
नहीं है तो मैंने स्टाइल नहीं है एम के
डियर कमांड का उसे करो उसके बाद एम के
डियर आईफोन m700 उसके बाद डॉट एस एस तो ये
इस परमिशन के साथ आपकी फाइल डायरेक्टली
क्रिएट हो जाएगी एक चीज ध्यान में रखना ये
डायरेक्टर होने के बाद क्या आपको ये मेक
सर करना है की इसकी जो परमीशंस हनी है वो
700 होने चाहिए इसके अलावा उसके ऊपर कोई
भी परमिशन नहीं हनी चाहिए बस इतना था अब
मैं क्या करता हूं सीडी करता हूं अगर इसके
अंदर चेक भी करता हूं कुछ है या नहीं किया
ये टेंडर हेलो करके दिखाऊं अभी क्या इसमें
बहुत कुछ है अभी इसके अंदर बहुत कुछ है
क्योंकि जब भी हमें असेट्स के थ्रू
कम्युनिकेशन हुआ तो ऑटोमेटेकली यहां पे की
शेर होगी अब मैं क्या करता हूं एक बार
रिमूव कर देता हूं रिमूव जो ऐसे रिमूव कर
देता हूं ये तंत्र अभी हमें एलएस करके
दिखाऊं एलएस है करके दिखता हूं कुछ भी
अलग-अलग करके दिखाओ अभी भी क्या टोटल जीरो
दिखा रहा है ओके हम क्या करते हैं अभी
काली इमेज ले जाते हैं तो काली में शिफ्ट
करते हैं तो अभी क्या है की मुझे शेर करना
है तो एक सबसे आसन तरीका है शेर करने का
बिल्कुल एक कमांडर हो जाएगा कम कैसे शेर
करेंगे अगर आपको अपनी पब्लिक की को शेर
करना है उसके लिए एक कमांड होती है
कमांड होती है उसके बाद हिफिन हाय उसे
करना है उसके बाद वो फूल पाठ आपको मेंशन
करना है जिसके अंदर आपकी वो की है तो मेरी
होम डायरेक्टरी में है उसके बाद मैं क्या
कर रहा हूं डॉट एस एस हा डॉट एस हा उसके
बाद नया क्या है
ये मेरा उसका क्या है पाठ है ये मेरा क्या
है उसका पाठ है तो
ये क्या किया मैंने से कॉपी आईडी उसके बाद
आई ये फूल मैंने दिया उसके बाद क्या है की
यूजर नाम जो उसका नाम है क्योंकि मुझे शेर
करना
दिखता हूं तो ये इसका एड्रेस है
कॉन्फिडेंस
सर्विस चल रही है इसलिए सर कम हो रहा है
ओके तो अब मैं क्या करूंगा सिंपली हिट
अंदर कर दूंगा अभी ये क्या बोला वन तू
कंटिन्यू कनेक्टिंग यस यस आई एम सर फर्स्ट
टाइम अगर कनेक्ट करने कोशिश करोगे ये कब
आता है ये जब आता है जब आप फर्स्ट टाइम
किसी मशीन के साथ असर के थ्रू कंपनी एड
करते हो क्योंकि जब ये बैकग्राउंड में
अपने आप भी की एक्सचेंज कर रही होती है जब
भी एक ही एक्सचेंज को भी होती है यस और
ओके आप पासवर्ड दीजिए मुझे अपना ओके इसका
भी मैंने पासवर्ड इंटर कर दिया
तो अभी क्या हुआ की इसमें क्या होता है
नंबर ऑफ ये क्या हो गया की पासवर्ड ले
सकते हैं हमारी मशीन रेडी है पासवर्ड लेंस
पसंद है हमारी मशीन रेडी है कैसे अभी मैं
आपको दिखता हूं पहले कम किया जाते हैं
आपको यहां पर देखो ऑथराइज्ड की के नाम से
एक फाइल की रेट होगी
जो मैंने आपको तब स्क्रीन पे दिखाए था यही
वो पब्लिक की है तो अब हम क्या करते हैं
अब मैं इसकी मैं क्या करता हूं
श उसके बाद मैंने क्या किया
पासवर्ड
अगर मैं एलएस करके दिखाऊं तो साड़ी चीज
आपको देखने को मिल रही है इधर अगर एलएस
आईफोन अल करके दिखाओ तो ये आपको डॉट वाली
डायरेक्ट इधर भी देखने को मिल रही होगी
अगर मैं इसके अंदर शेड ही करता हूं उसके
बाद डॉट एस हा के अंदर जाता हूं डायरेक्टर
के अंदर और एलएस करता हूं फिर ऑर्गेनाइज्ड
की के नाम से आपको देखने को मिल गया अगर
मैं कैंट करता हूं तो राइस की को तो ये वो
से फाइल है
ये देखो ये वही चीज है तो इस तरीके से हम
किसी भी मशीन के साथ पासवर्ड
कर सकते हैं
क्या कर सकते हैं पासवर्ड ली ऑथेंटिकेशन
सेट कर सकते हैं
हम कैसे सेट कर सकते हैं अगर इसमें भी एक
और सीकर स्टेप करना है तो आप जब भी
एचएसएससी जैन कमांडर उसे करोगे जब आप की
जेनरेट करते हो वापस वो आपको पास फिर
मांगता है पासवर्ड मांगता है तो वहां पर
पासवर्ड सेट कर दीजिए तो जिससे की अगर कोई
आपकी प्राइवेट की को स्टॉल भी कर लगा
चूड़ा भी कर ले चूड़ा भी लगा तब भी क्या
है की वह उसको उसे नहीं कर पाया क्योंकि
उसके लिए उसको गुड पोस्ट करना पड़ेगा ओके
तो यह था आपका पासवर्ड ली ऑथेंटिकेशन
तरीका तो प्लीज एक बार मुझे ये बताइए की
आप लोगों को अभी तक जो भी कुछ मैंने बताया
एसएससी लेटेस्ट सब कुछ समझ में आया या
नहीं आया बताइए
प्लीज चाट में जल्दी जल्दी बता दीजिए
मुझे भी कुछ क्रिएटिव करके देखो ना
हर चीज कोई आपको हर चीज सिखाएगा हर चीज
अगर आपको
स्पून फीडिंग करेगा
[संगीत]
अगर मैं चाहता हूं की जो मेरा यूजर है मैं
मेरा सरवर है क्योंकि मेरा
पर एग्जांपल अभी मैंने क्या किया जो मैं
काली मशीन है मैं चाहता हूं की कोई भी
यूजर्स मेरी मशीन के साथ एवं मैं भी जब भी
मैं ट्राई करूं से के थ्रू लॉगिन करने के
लिए दिउ तू सिक्योरिटी रीजंस वो रूट से
लॉगिन ना कर पे वो कभी भी रूट अकाउंट से
लॉगिन ना कर पे अगर वो लोग इन कर भी पे तो
नॉर्मल यूजर अकाउंट से ही कर पे तो वो चीज
को अगर मुझे रिस्टिक करना है तो मैं कैसे
करूंगा तो सिंपली मुझे क्या करना है उसके
लिए मुझे मेरी इसकी में क्वालिफिकेशन फाइल
के अंदर जाना पड़ेगा उससे पहले मुझे रूट
बन्ना पड़ेगा और उसमें ओके
अब मैं क्या करता हूं की मुझे पहले सीडी
करता हूं मुझे सीडी करना है स्लैश ईटीसी
के अंदर जाना हो से के जो में कनफ्लिक्ट
भी है उनके यहां पर जाना है मुझे एलएस
करके दिखाना आपको एलएस तो यहां पर क्या है
की आपको
नाम से देख रहे हो
की तो मुझे क्या करना है यहां पर
बम करना है
ओपन करना है
तो यहां पर आपको देखने को मिल रहा है इसके
अंदर बहुत साड़ी सेटिंग्स है
की जो कोई भी यूजर अगर मेरी मशीन से
रीमोटली एक्सेस करने की कोशिश करता है तो
मैं क्या चाहता हूं की वो रिमोट रूट यूजर
अकाउंट से उसको एक्सेस ना कर पे उसके लिए
पहले मुझे इसमें सर्च करता हूं आपको पता
है विम में सर्च कैसे करते हैं अभी मैं
क्या करता हूं यहां पर
परमिट मैं क्या करता हूं इसमें एक पिरामिड
होता है परमिट होगी ये देखो ये आपके सामने
ए गया स्क्रीन पर
प्रोबेबिलिटी दिखा रहा है बट ये कमेंट कर
रहा है इसका मतलब क्या भाई रिपोर्ट सेटिंग
के साथ चला है तो मैं क्या चाहता हूं अभी
इसको मैं दिउ तू सिक्योरिटी रीजंस इंसर्ट
मोड में राहत हूं
इसको कमेंट आउट करता हूं मैं उसके बाद मैं
यहां पर क्या लिख देता हूं रोहिटेड
पासवर्ड
नो कर दिया मैंने इसको कर दिया नो मैं
कहता हूं की कोई भी व्यक्ति अगर मेरी मशीन
के शो एसेस करता है तो वो मेरे रूट यूजर
के थ्रू कभी भी एक्सेस ना कर पे ओके इसके
बाद में इसको क्या करता हूं से करता हूं
उसके बाद शिफ्ट और राइट और क्यूट उसके बाद
मुझे सर्विस पर क्या करना है रीस्टार्ट
करना पड़ेगा सो डेट की जो हमारे मशीन से
जो हमारे डिमांड सर्विस
मैंने चेंज किया है उनको क्या कर पे सही
से रीड कर पे तो ओके तो मैं क्या करूंगा
सर्विस रीस्टार्ट एस एस तो ये मैंने
स्टार्ट कर दी अब मैं क्या करता हूं मैं
एसिस्ट करने की कोशिश करता हूं कैसे चलो
मेरा मोबाइल
ओके चलेगा
इसके अंदर क्या कर पाऊंगा इंटर कर पाऊंगा
लोग आउट
लोग आउट कर दिया मैंने अब मैं एसएमएस करता
हूं उसके बाद हम रूट के रूट के थ्रू करता
हूं
@
1922 16
अभी मैं पासवर्ड डालता हूं रूट का
भी क्या आएगा
ही नहीं
कितनी बार ट्राई करो
परमिशन डिनाइड पब्लिकली और पासवर्ड पब्लिक
की पासवर्ड
भी दे रहा है और जबकि मैं हर बार तीनों
टाइम अपना पासपोर्ट सही दाल रहा हूं इसके
अंदर तो एक तो ये कम कर सकते हो आप की आप
क्या कर सकते हो किसी को भी स्टिक कर सकते
हो दूसरा कम क्या कर सकते हैं ड्यूटी
सिक्योरिटी रीजन आप क्या चाहते हो की आप
चाहते हो की की जब भी कोई मेरी मशीन को
क्योंकि आप एक अटैक हो तो आप भी तो अपने
आप कुछ हायड करना चाहोगे ना
अभी तो क्या करोगे अपने आप को हायड करना
चाहोगे जब आप अपने आप को हायड करना चाहोगे
तो क्या करना चाहोगे तो आप जो बाय
डिफॉल्टर जो पोर्ट है उसका वो 22 होता है
लेकिन क्या करोगे जब भी कोई आपकी सर्विस
में प्रधान किया किसी ने आपकी सर्विस को
स्कैन किया सर्विस को स्कैन करते हैं उसके
पता चला गया ओके हां आपकी मशीन का तो एक
पोर्ट नंबर 22 पे एक सर्विस चल रही है स
नाम की तो क्या करेगा उसको एन्यूमैरेट
करने की कोशिश करेगा उसको अटैक करने की
कोशिश करेगा लेकिन दिउ तू सिक्योरिटी रीजन
क्या करते हैं मुझे वो बाय डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट
चेंज कर देते हैं तो वो बाय डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट
कैसे चेंज होता है वो भी आपको दिखता हूं
रीम एक्सेस भी कन्फ्यूजन वाली फाइल को ओपन
करना है अभी मैं क्या करता हूं उसको वापस
फिर से कर देता हूं जैसे का जैसा था कोई
बात नहीं 9 चलेगा 9 चलने दो मुझे कोई
सुनिए और रोटी से मुझे करना नहीं है इसमें
उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं एक आपको देखने
को मिलेगा सबसे पहले एयरपोर्ट वाले
एयरपोर्ट
22 लिखा हुआ है यहां पर क्या कर सकते हो
आप इंसर्ट मोड में जाइए आप कोई जो भी
पोर्ट है लेकिन आपको पोर्ट वो डालना है जो
आपकी में अवेलेबल हो ना ऐसा किया
है जो आपकी मशीन में फ्री हो तो जैसे की
मैंने लिया
5152 कोड दाल दिया ओके और मैंने क्या कर
दिया इसको फिर एस्केप मोड किया उसके बाद
क्यूट एंड्राइड किया और मैं अभी फिर से
अपनी सर्विस को रीस्टार्ट कर देता हूं
सिस्टर रीस्टार्ट मैंने अपनी सर्विस कर
दिया अब मैं क्या करता हूं फिर से मैं
अपनी मशीन में लॉगिन करने की कोशिश करता
हूं अभी मैंने बाय डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट चेंज कर
दिया तो अभी मैं क्या करूंगा असेट्स करता
हूं मैं नॉर्मल जैसे ही टेंडर किया मैंने
देखो अभी ये कुछ भी रिस्पांस नहीं बोला
कनेक्शन क्यों कनेक्शन तू होस्ट 194 20
मतलब 422 पे ऐसा कोई कनेक्शन है ही नहीं
अगर अब आपको कनेक्शन करना है तो सिंपली
हिफिन पी फ्लैग देना है उसमें बाद आपको
मेंशन करना पड़ेगा कौन से पोर्ट पे 515
के लिए आपको प्रमोट किया
आप अपनी मशीन के अंदर इंटर कर गए इस तरीके
से आप क्या है कोई भी पोर्ट चेंज कर सकते
हो उसके बाद जब आपको असेट्स करोगे तो आपको
स्पेशली वो पोर्ट मेंशन करना पड़ेगा
एडरवाइज बाय करेगा
22 22 आपने क्या कर दिया डिसएबल कर दिया
इसका मतलब क्या है की आप उसके साथ लॉगिन
नहीं कर पाओगे 42 के साथ मैं फिर से क्या
है बाय डिफॉल्टर कर देता हूं अदर वाइस या
कल को मुझे जरूर पड़ेगी
तो ओके
इंस्टेंट मोड जाता हूं नेक्स्ट
वीडियो
एग्जांपल
उसे करें जी पर काली उसे कर रहे हो और आप
क्या चाहते हो की इसके जो पर्टिकुलर
यूजर्स है
पता चला की हम तीन लोग ही हो आप तीन लोग
ही चाहते हो की हम ही इस मशीन को एक्सेस
कर
पाव एक्सेस कर पाव पर एग्जांपल मेरे पास
कौन-कौन करता हूं
अभी मैं कहता हूं की मेरा यूजर वन है और
यूजर तू है वही
मेरी मशीनों को क्या कर पाएं एक्सेस कर पे
रे मोती स के थ्रू अगर मैं ये कम भी करना
चाहता हूं वो भी मैं कर सकता हूं उसके लिए
मुझे कौन सा एक पैरामीटर के साथ चेंज चेंज
चेंज करना पड़ेगा मुझे सबसे लास्ट में
जाना है इस फाइल के बिल्कुल और ऑफ डी फाइल
जाना है और ऑफ डी लाइन जो आपको जहां पे
आपके लायक ओके और ऑफ डी लाइन के आपको
इनसाइड मॉडल में जाना है उसके बाद आपको
ज्यादा इंसर्ट मोड में ओके विथ इंटर करके
आपको क्या है लिखना है यहां पर आपको लिखना
है यहां पर एक लाइन एड कर देनी है वो लाइन
कौन सी है उसको बोलेंगे हम ए डबल ल ओ ब्लू
यूजर्स यू एस ए आर अलाव यूजर्स उसके बाद
आपको क्या करना है यूजर का नाम मैंने क्या
लिखा यूजर वन उसके बाद
यूजर 2 यूजर वन और यूजर तू एक बार मुझे
क्या करना है कंफर्म करना पड़ेगा क्या
उनका नाम एग्जैक्ट में क्या है
कर देता हूं
के लिए करता हूं
दी आई एफ आर ओ एन आई एन आई
एफ आर ओ एन आई एक्स डिक्रोनिक्स हो गया अब
मैं यूजर वन के लिए रख देता हूं इसको
[संगीत]
ट्राई नहीं किया है तो चलो हम करते हैं
अब कल ही तुम्हें एक्सेस कर पाएंगे
एफ आर ओ एन आई एक्स डिप्रॉनिक्स अभी देखो
इसके थ्रू मैं क्या कर पाया लॉगिन कर पाया
इसके थ्रू ना क्या कर पाया लॉगिन कर पाया
पीडी करके दिखता हूं ये रहा रूट के अंदर
हो अगर मैं आपको करता हूं और डॉलर
ठीक है अब मैं क्या करता हूं अभी यूजर वन
था मेरा हमें यूजर 2 से करके देखा हूं
यूजर तू से करके देखा हूं ओके तू यू ट्री
करता हूं तो दी ए एफ आर ओ एन अरे यार
पासवर्ड गलत हो गया मेरा ओके दोबारा ट्राई
करता हूं मैं दी आई एफ आर ओ एन आई एक्स
डेफ्रॉनिक्स की इंटर तो इसके थ्रू भी मैं
कर पाया क्या कर पाया अपनी मशीन के अंदर
इंटर कर पाया लॉगआउट कर देता हूं मैं
एग्जिट कर देता हूं लोग आउट हो नहीं रहा
है ओके तो फिर से अब मैं क्या यूजर थ्री
के साथ करते देता हूं क्योंकि इसको तो
परमिशन नहीं देना चलो ठीक है इसके साथ
करते हैं
अब मैं क्या करता हूं फिर से दे एफ आर ओ
एन आई एक्स डिप्रॉनिक्स देखिए अब इसको
परमिशन नहीं मिलेगी तो इस तरीके से आप
क्या कर सकते हो किसी पट्टी को अलाउ चलाओ
भी कर सकते हो अगर आप चाहते हो की किसी
ओनली
को हटा देता हूं
अगर आपको क्या करना हम आपको देख शिखा देता
हूं अगर पर्टिकुलर क्या था की इन तीन यूजर
कोई बन करना चाहते हैं और बाकी सभी को
क्या करना चाहते हैं तो आप अलाउ की तरह
क्या करोगे 20 अलाउड करोगे क्या करोगे 20
दी आई एस डिश
सॉरी सॉरी
यूजर्स के नाम यूजर वन और
ऐसे भी कर सकते हैं एक तरीका अगर आप क्या
चाहते हो किसी पर्टिकुलर आईपी एड्रेस को
ही आईपी एड्रेस को सभी यूजर्स को क्या
करना चाहते हो बन करना चाहते हो वो भी कर
सकते हो कैसे कर सकते हो
मैंने क्या किया इसका उसके बाद @ उसके बाद
मैंने लिखा
123939 का कोई भी यूजर अगर हमें एक्सेस
करने की कोशिश करेगा तो मैं उसको क्या का
रहा हूं दिन कर रहा हूं वो उसको एक्सेस
नहीं कर पाएगा अगर आप चाहे तो पूरे बैंड
को क्या कर सकते हो एक्सेस करने से हो
सकते हो सिंपली कैसे आते डी रेट
168.1.0 उसके बाद ये पूरा सब नेट मास्क
उसके पूरा-पूरा इसने क्या किया था पूरे
सबने मास को भी क्या कर दिया इसने
1926.1.0
को क्या करने कोशिश करेंगे अगर एक्सेस
करने की कोशिश करेगा उसको क्या कर देगा
देना है कर देगा तो इस तरीके से आप कैसे
कर सकते हो दिन भी कर सकते हो और अगर आप
अलाउ करना चाहते हो तो पट्टी में किसी
आईपी एड्रेस को ही अलाउ करना चाहते हो
उसके सभी यूजर्स को आउट करना चाहते हो तो
सिंपली क्या करोगे अलाव यूजर्स स्टार आते
डी रेट आईपीएल इस तरीके से आप यहां पर
मेंशन कर सकते अगर आपके साथ ऐसी कोई
कंडीशन आई जैसे की आपके पास पता चला की आप
10 लोग हो तो आप 10 यूजेस की एंट्री करने
की बजे आप क्या करोगे ऐसा ग्रुप क्रिएट
करोगे पर एग्जांपल कोई भी ग्रुप क्रिएट कर
लिया और उन 10 के 10 यूजर को क्या कहना एक
ग्रुप ग्रुप में अगर आप एड कर दो और क्या
कर सकते हो उसे पूरे ग्रुप को क्या कर
सकते हो आप से की परमिशन दे सकते हो ग्रुप
को क्या कर सकते हैं इसके अंदर दे सकते हो
कैसे उसके लिए आप सिंपली क्या लिखोगे
उसे ग्रुप का नाम देना है जिसको
एंट्री की हुई है तो इस तरीके से आप क्या
कर सकते हो किसी भी पट्टी को यूजर को किसी
भी पट्टी यूजर को अलाउड किसी भी पर्टिकुलर
देना है किसी भी पर्टिकुलर आईपी एड्रेस को
लाउड किसी पेट का आईपी सब नेट मास्क फूड
डिनर
ठीक है फिर हम सेशन
में पढ़ने को बहुत कुछ है बट उसे लेवल का
आप लोगों पढ़ने की जरूर नहीं है इससे
ज्यादा आप लोगों को जान की जरूर नहीं है
तो एक्सेस को चाहे तो हम आधा घंटा और 1
घंटा और बड़ा सकते हैं इतना बड़ा टॉपिक है
अपने आप में
ओके तो
है तो निर्देशक हैंडल आईटी की लिंकडइन में
कमेंट नहीं कर का रहा है थोड़ा लकी क्या
प्रॉब्लम
कर लेंगे या कोई भी हमारा टीम का मेंबर
आपको क्या कर लिया कांटेक्ट कर लगा क्यों
नहीं कर का रहा है क्या इशू ए रहा है नो
इशू लकी कोई सुनिए आपको भी हमारी टीम का
मेंबर्स है जो अभी चाट में अवेलेबल है वो
क्या कर ले आपको कांटेक्ट कर लगा तो ठीक
है फिर हम क्या करते हैं सेशन को एड करते
हैं तो ये हमारा लास्ट सेशन था हमारा लेने
कैप्सूल पोस्ट का आई होप की पूरा कोर्स आप
लोगों ने एंजॉय किया होगा और इसके बाद
क्या किया हमारा नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन का
जल्दी स्टार्ट हो गई है की आयोग की वजह आप
लोगों को क्या किया होगा बर नहीं किया
होगा और आप लोगों को ज्यादा
पकाया नहीं होगा अगर अगर आप लोगों को ऐसा
लगता है की मैंने आप लोगों को सही से नहीं
पटाया या मैंने आप लोगों को कॉन्सेप्ट
डिलीवरी में थोड़े कमी छोड़ी है या मैंने
कुछ ऐसा
नहीं पटाया था उसके लिए हम रियली सॉरी
मैंने अपनी तरफ से 100% दिया आप लोगों को
जितना आपको 15 डेज में दे सकता था
दूसरा कंटेंट डिलीवरी तो नहीं कर सकता कोई
भी और प्लीज अगर आप लोगों को हमारा कोर्स
पसंद आया चाहे आप रिकॉर्डिंग सेशन देख रहे
हो चाहे आप लाइव सेशन देख रहे हो तो प्लीज
सब्सक्राइब कमेंट करना मत भूलिए अगर आप
चैनल पर आए हैं देखने के लिए आई होप की आप
लोगों को काफी मजा आया होगा काफी कुछ आपको
सीखने को मिला होगा पुरी सीरीज में और
प्लीज आप लोगों से एक और रिक्वेस्ट है की
जैसे हमारे को सेंड हो जाता है जैसे ही
वहां जाता है तो हमारा क्या होता है की
लिंकडइन पेज है हमारी वेबसाइट का जो हमारे
लिंक में लिंक नीचे दिया हो तो वहां पर
जाइए और प्लीज कभी भी चाहे आप इस वीडियो
को 10 दिन के बाद देख रहे हो एक महीने के
बाद देख रहे हो या चाहे आप उसको 1 साल के
बाद देख लो कभी भी आप इस वीडियो को देख
रहे हो या इस पुरी सीरीज को देख लो प्लीज
हर एक सीरीज के लिए हर एक वीडियो के लिए
एक वेब पेज जो हमारा लिंकडइन का वेब पेज
है
उसे पर अवेलेबल है वहां जाइए और प्लीज
कमेंट करके बताइए क्या आप लोगों को समझ
में आया नहीं आया और कितना आप लोगों को
हमारा पोस्ट पसंद आया नहीं आया प्लीज
कमेंट करना मत भूलिए इससे क्या है की आप
लोगों को हमारी काफी हेल्प हम लोग वो आपकी
काफी हेल्प मिलेगी आगे और जिसकी वजह से
आपके ऐसा करके आप अपना ही नहीं बल्कि किसी
दूसरे लोगों का भी फायदा करोगे क्योंकि
उनको पता चलेगा की सच में इधर कुछ सीखने
को मिला है अगर नहीं भी सीखने को मिला तो
प्लीज वो भी बता दीजिए हम आगे जो उसको
थोड़ा सा और ध्यान रखेंगे तो
इस कैप्सूल को उसके लिए बाय बाय करते हैं
और करते हैं
तो बाय बाय
टेक केयर